foreign
hey can you help me with something in
the bedroom real quick yeah sure one sec
no now actually this is super fast hey
Matt hey
okay
hey
what's going on yeah
Jesus what is it okay so I can show you
something real quick
okay
I love Kelly Monroe it's not about her
revealed
Miller left something behind in this
alley a blood-soaked blue booty the type
worn over Shoes by a variety of home
service providers LAPD forensics is
[Music]
that doesn't I mean what are you saying
did Matt notice the girl at the bar the
other night my girl
be the dead body the girl that was
murdered you left right after she did oh
my God
oh my God ratchets all over his arms
what yes yes big red angry new scratches
okay and he said his cat did it
I don't think he has a kid oh
Matt he's so
ber I know my Killers it is him and he
is right there
but he can't be it can't be
do you wanna do you want to just go
ahead and ask him because he has the
same blue boot he says the killer he
followed the girl out of the park an
hour later she was stabbed 37 times and
then he waltzes in this morning with
don't kill me scratches on his arms from
his imaginary cat okay what more do you
want I've hung out with him a dozen
times he's just a normal guy okay do you
think Ted Bundy wore a t-shirt I [__]
corpses I beg you you gotta stop
listening to these podcasts what do you
guys talk about how well do you know him
what's what's going on with your little
friend over there
all the time what do you talk about just
normal stuff guys stuff like what he
told me he's got a kid
no I it you know it sucks he used to
live in uh Pomona Pomona okay what
what
Los Angeles because someone got attacked
in his apartment building shut up are
you serious attacked in his building in
Pomona oh my God okay what else what
else was that I mean I think it was like
two years ago
okay
24 murders what the [__] is up with that
our suspects here let's see I saw murder
of 82 year old Sharon Simpson that's
that's not a thing he he murders really
young hot brunettes like
what murder an apartment building 242
work Street police found the victim
Nicole Gibson Snapchat
because he said that the his apartment
building was next to some tennis courts
okay
you mean those tennis scores oh my gosh
oh [__] oh my god oh [__]
didn't find me attractive enough to kill
but whatever oh really really I'm just
saying I'm sure there'll be other serial
killers that find you hot enough to kill
why would he just mention Pomona he just
volunteered because he's getting off on
it he is
I know these guys BTK zodiac they love
to secretly boast that no one can
actually catch them think about it think
about it
world that is just the toilet guy but
deep inside he has the secret a huge
powerful secret I mean can you imagine
if they knew he was the West Side River
hey guys hey hey hi hi
uh sorry I'm just headed out but um what
did you want to tell me back there
what was it I was good yeah uh back
there
life
before
when we were back there yeah hmm would
you
I have you know it's crazy I have no
idea oh my God
no idea he does this all the time now
he's worried oh no we'll get it worked
on call the doctor for you yeah
this guy listen uh in that case
I got some bad news
boy
the last hot water pipe is leaking oh
look I tried to patch it but we're gonna
have to change it out I just did one oh
my God you guys to curse me when I'm
gone y'all you we would the last person
we would curse okay well you know I'll
uh I'll pick one up bring it back
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]